how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we actually
have some really big news about the
falcon
and the winter soldier last night a
leaked set photo came out
showing bucky and falcon teeming with an
unexpected villain
now this photo was immediately removed
from the instagram page that it was
originally posted on and then it was
removed from twitter accounts and other
instagram accounts as well so clearly
marvel did not want this photo getting
out and they were right to do so because
it contains a pretty decent sized
spoiler in it and it also seemingly
confirms a plot leak that we got not too
long ago that says we're going to see
the mutant omega
red so i'll break down this photo and
talk about this plot leak and what it
means for the falcon and the winter
soldier in this video but first
big congratulations to youtube user
major
gaming for being the winner of last
week's loki funko pop
email me in the email in my description
and i'll get you your prize and for this
week we're giving away an iron spider
funko pop all you got to do to enter
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below
now as i mentioned in the beginning this
photo has been taken down
on all of the platforms that it was
posted so far so unfortunately i can't
show it due to copyright reasons but i
did see it and i can describe what i saw
but if you are trying to avoid
any and all spoilers for the falcon in
the winter soldier you should click away
now
if you're still with me the photo that
we saw was of the falcon and the winter
soldier
bucky and sam teaming up with baron zemo
now in this photo it is very clear that
they were on the same side
fighting other people in the photo they
are literally standing side by side
while facing the people that they are
fighting
or about to fight now it was just one
photo that was shared but again it's
very obvious what is going on here but
what this really tells us
is that a leaked episode description
that we once heard
for the falcon and the winter soldier
could be very real now
originally it did sound very legitimate
and now this leaked photo does confirm
one of the things that the league said
was going to happen the leaked episode
description actually talked about the
falcon and the winter soldier teaming up
with baron zemo so let's go over this
episode description and talk about what
else it said
this was the description for the leaked
episode sam
isn't allowed to be cap because of the
events of civil war
but trust u.s agent to take over the
mantle u.s
agent genuinely wants to do a good job
and doesn't realize
he's part of a bigger plan sam and bucky
have to work with zemo to track down a
crime syndicate called the alchemist
zemo is essentially their hostage but he
has vital information so the leaked
photo that went out last night and then
was taken down
showed bucky and sam with zemo
confirming this scene
and as it continues it says they go to
madrapore with him and there they meet
botrok the leaper
and omega red it goes on to say overall
the show feels a lot like winter soldier
and the mission impossible movies
agent 13 and bucky seem to have a
romance very flirty vibes
sam judges bucky for it and bucky says
steve dated her like 70 years ago he
also said that william hurt aka
thunderbolt ross is in the show as well
and seemed to reference black widow
so a pretty big part of this episode
description has already been confirmed
to be true by this leaked photo so
there's a very high chance that the rest
of this leak
could be a true leak of this episode and
if it is the very last line of what this
person said who saw this episode
apparently
is very important the last line says
zemo escapes from them in a speedboat to
end
the episode which of course i guess
everybody could see coming so if this is
true
zemo will work with bucky and sam but
only temporarily
after all this is the guy that really
tried to get the avengers to kill each
other
so it's not really that big of a
surprise now there's actually another
confirmation to this episode leak and
that is batrack the leaper but truck the
leaper was
in captain america winter soldier but
this leak says that he's coming back
and in some recent leaked photos we do
in fact see but rock the leaper so two
things basically confirming that this
episode plot leak is
in fact legitimate which means that the
mutant omega red
will appear in the falcon and the winter
soldier mutants will be coming to the
mcu
in phase four now omega red is a pretty
intense mutant villain and he has the
typical powers that a normal super
person would have
superhuman strength ability speed etc
but he also has a healing factor like
wolverine and he can produce pheromones
that are actually
poison and not to mention the
carbonadium retractable tentacles that
he has in each of his arms but the most
important thing that we need to know
about omega red is that he
is heavily connected to russia and the
red room
now we've heard and we all assume that
black widow has to come out before
the falcon and the winter soldier come
out and of course that is because it
said that black widow has some plot
details that will affect and go on to
lead into the falcon and the winter
soldier
and omega red could be that connection
we know black widow is basically going
to be all about the red room and
considering omega
red's connection to it and the fact that
he's going to be in the falcon in the
winter soldier i think we found it so in
one way or another concerning russia and
the red room omega red is going to be
that connection and it looks like sam
and bucky are definitely going to have
their hands full with him
another thing that we can probably
assume is going on here is the setup of
the thunderbolts the episode league says
that u.s agent genuinely wants to do a
good job he wants to be a good
captain america but it does say that
he's part of a bigger plan
and we also have heard that thunderbolt
ross is going to be in the show as well
now this is also another connection to
black widow as we know that thunderbolt
ross will be in black widow as well
in fact we've seen him in the trailers
and we know that thunderbolt ross really
wants some super soldier serum that's
his thing in the comics and that's been
his thing since the incredible hulk
now we know that he's been experimenting
with some super soldier serum and we
know that the black widows in the red
room are actually given a type of super
soldier serum as well
but at the same time it's actually a
mind control device
and rumors have said that us agent john
walker is going to receive this same
super soldier serum so even though he
wants to do good unfortunately he's most
likely going to be controlled by
thunderbolt ross
and that puts him as part of this
so-called bigger plan that the episode
leak talks about
now what thunderbolt ross is most likely
doing is setting up and recruiting the
thunderbolts with baron zemo probably
being one of them
if sam isn't allowed to be the new
captain america due to what happened
during civil war and then he goes on
with bucky
another war criminal to start doing
investigations of their own
that's definitely not going to sit very
well with thunderbolt ross and he's
definitely going to want to stop them
and
him being kind of a diabolical person
who better would he send to stop them
than baron zemo the person who basically
had somewhat of a control over bucky at
one point in time so as sam and bucky
have to work with baron zemo there's no
doubt
that ross already talked to him and the
fact that berensimo escapes in a
speedboat at the end was probably
planned as well
but thunderbolt ross doesn't like people
getting their own way he likes
everything to go exactly as he planned
and zemo is still a criminal and ross
just isn't going to let him go
spend all that time all that effort
and to see it feel
so spectacular
did it instead he's going to recruit him
for
the thunderbolts that way he can control
baron zemo and use him to do his work
for him we also assume that yelena
belova from black widow is going to be
joining the thunderbolts as well
possibly justin hammer from iron man 2
and ghost from ant-man and the wasp and
let's not forget
thunderbolt ross himself as red hulk
this would be a
pretty awesome thunderbolts team one
that i personally wouldn't mind seeing
in the mcu and connecting to black widow
the falcon and the winter soldier and
other movies and shows as well so it
looks like this episode description
is legitimate and we're going to be
getting omega red in phase 4
a mutant in phase four let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below
and let me know what you think about the
thunderbolts and this leaked episode
description as well
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news
don't forget to give the video a like
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram
and twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
me